[Musique]
c'est au stade ça de la garriga de
saint-andré que s'est déroulée la
deuxième édition du challenge sportif
départemental des collèges pour cette
occasion plus de 1000 jeunes étaient
rassemblés autour des valeurs du sport
[Musique]
huit épreuves physiques et sportifs
permettait le classement par points de
l'escaladé des échasses soulever des
pneus relais 4 100 m un moment des fêtes
pour nos jeunes et la presse on s'est
dit on accroche normalement d'autres
choses comme la pieuvre changé d'épaulés
tout à l'heure je crains si vous étiez
là où normalement on accroche plein de
choses comme ça dessus et là on a le
coeur du sport mais aussi des ateliers
pour sensibiliser les jeunes à la
protection de l'environnement ou encore
à la santé et à la nutrition
[Musique]
les 25 premiers collèges remporte une
dotation qui permettra d'acquérir des
petits matériels sportifs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]